a unique melody to open the trade fair
Mongolia's in the spotlight for this
year's ITB in Berlin the country is
presenting its culture scenery and the
capital rule on bart or last year it
drew just 450 thousand tourists the one
thing is our location between two giant
countries a Russian Federation in
Chinese Republic and in order to go to
Mongolia you have to cross those two
countries but if you once crossed those
two countries by air or by length you
will have great place to rest meanwhile
tourism is booming again in Greece
travel there increased by a fifth last
year seeing 21 and a half million guests
its a bright spot in the economic crisis
plaguing the country this year grace
also features smaller mainland
destinations to increase bookings there
too analysts say tourism worldwide is
doing solid business but some operators
see dark clouds on the horizon biscuit
global AHA's for there are global
challenges there's a lot of tension in
the world so far we haven't felt that in
Germany and we don't expect to in 2015
but the challenges remain some countries
have many economic difficulties there
are plenty of regional issues too Yamba
do you wonder stories Morse not everyone
is pessimistic though especially in
Germany people there are spending more
money on travel than ever before